thank you very much everyone
our country is in the midst of a great
national trial unlike any we have ever
faced before you all see it you see it
probably better than most word war with
a deadly virus success in this fight
will require the full absolute measure
of our collective strength love and
devotion very important each of us has
the power through our own choices and
actions to save American lives and
rescue the most vulnerable among us
that's why we really have to do what we
all know is right every citizen is being
called upon to make sacrifices every
business is being asked to fulfill its
patriotic duty every community is making
fundamental changes to how we live work
and interact each and every day and I
wouldn't be surprised to see this going
on long into the future when this virus
is gone and defeated some of the things
we're doing now will be very good
practice for the future including for
not getting the flu which is very
devastating also so some of what we're
learning now will live on into the
future I really believe that shaking
hands or not shaking hands washing hands
all the time staying a little apart 15
days ago we published our nationwide
guidelines to slow the spread of the
virus on Sunday I announced that this
campaign will be extended until April
30th
in a few moments dr. Burks will explain
the data that formed the basis for our
decision
to extend the guidelines and dr. Falchi
will explain why it's absolutely
critical for the American people to
follow the guidelines for the next 30
days it's a matter of life and death
frankly it's a matter of life and death
I know our citizens will rise to the
occasion and they already have
sacrificed a lot we had the greatest
economy in the history of our country
we're the greatest economy in the world
we had the best unemployment numbers and
employment numbers that we've ever had
by far and in one instant we said we
have no choice but to close it up just
as Americans have always done they will
do a job like few have seen before and
they're proud to do it I see that
there's a great pride going on right to
him before we hear from our experts we
have a few other announcement today the
Treasury Department and Small Business
Administration announced further details
on the Paycheck protection program which
was made possible by the two trillion
dollar relief bill I signed into law
last week nearly three hundred and fifty
billion dollars in loans will soon be
available through lending partners to
help small businesses meet payroll and
other expenses for up to two months
these loans will be forgiven as long as
businesses keep paying their workers
this includes sole proprietors and
independent contractors applications
will be accepted starting this Friday
April 3rd so on Friday April 3rd that's
what it begins earlier today I spoke
with leading Internet and phone
providers who are doing a tremendous job
of keeping our internet and lines of
communication flowing under very
strongly increased strain the businesses
more than anybody seen before because
everyone's inside they were all making
calls among the leaders i spoke to or
pons
vez berg of horizon communications
Randall Stephenson of AT&T Mike sievert
of t-mobile Thomas Rutledge of Charter
Communications Brian Roberts of Comcast
John Malone of Liberty Media Dexter
of Altice Michael Combs of Sprint and
Araya Birkhoff of Lyon tree also Pat
Esser of Cox Communications and Jeffery
story of CenturyLink they're doing an
incredible job if you look at other
continents if you look at Europe they
want a different route than we did and
much different route we were talking
about that just a little while ago and
they're having tremendous problems other
countries are having problems other
continents are having problems but with
business at a level that nobody's seen
it before on the internet it's holding
up incredibly well and they expect that
to continue no matter what happened and
no matter how much more it gains which
if it can gain more than it already is I
don't know because they're setting
records let me also update you on the
distribution of urgency needed resources
and supplies and we have a lot of
numbers I'm going to let Mike Pence
speak to that in a little while but
we're giving massive amounts of medical
equipment and supplies to the 50 states
we also are holding back quite a bit we
have almost 10,000 ventilators that we
have ready to go we have to hold them
back because the surge is coming and
it's coming pretty strong and we want to
be able to immediately move it into
place without going and taking it so
we're ready to go and we've also
distributed I just spoke with governor
of Michigan had a great conversation and
we sent a large number of ventilators to
Michigan we're sending them to Louisiana
we sent additional ventilators to New
York
additional ventilators to New Jersey
and I will say in New York FEMA is
supplying 250 ambulances and 500 EMTs to
help respond to the increasing caseload
that's a lot of ambulances in California
the Army Corps of Engineers is
developing eight facilities to expand
hospital capacity up to 50,000 beds
50,000 and had a great conversation last
night with Gavin Newsom he's doing he's
doing a really good job we were in
constant communications the USNS mercy
hospital ship is now operational it's in
Los Angeles and receiving patients and
in New York as you know the comfort
everybody watch that it's in place and
we'll be very short while receiving
large numbers of patients over a
thousand rooms and 12 operating rooms
FEMA's also provided a hundred travel
trailers to assist with housing needs
and we're ordering hundreds more in
Michigan FEMA will soon deliver in
addition to the ventilators 250 bed
field hospital and Army Corps of
Engineers is evaluating locations to
build alternate care facilities so we're
doing a field hospital in Michigan of
250 beds that we may be doubling it up
soon depending on the need they're doing
a good job with with beds in Michigan
but they may need more than the 250 so
FEMA and the Army Corps of Engineers are
prepared to go there quickly and get it
done in Louisiana we're delivering to
field hospitals to provide 500 new
hospital beds
I've been talking with the governor John
bel Edwards and the Army Corps of
Engineers has been really doing
incredible work establishing 3000 bed
alternate care site at the New Orleans
Convention Center which will be
operational believe it or not this week
so we're doing the 3,000
bed alternate care site and we're also
doing a 500 bed new hospital and that's
in Louisiana which really got hit it
started off very late and it was looking
good and then all of a sudden it just
reared up came from nowhere in addition
to the supplies were delivering we're
also giving hospitals the flexibility to
use new facilities including surgical
care centers to care for hospital
patients who are not infected for
example I know that many expectant
mothers are understandably concerned
about exposing their newborn babies to
the virus then they should be with our
action yesterday hospitals now have the
authority to create special areas for
mothers to deliver their babies in a
very safe and healthy environment
totally separate over the past two
months the US State Department has
organized one of the largest and most
complex international evacuation
operations in American history Mike
Pompeo has been working round-the-clock
along with ambassador O'Brien since
January 29th we have successfully
repatriated over 25,000 Americans from
more than 50 countries where they were
literally stuck in some cases locked in
and I salute the incredible public
servants at the Department of State as
well as their counterparts at DHS and
HHS who have played such an important
role in doing this you probably read
about the young people in Peru and young
people in Brazil and they were
absolutely stuck and we got them out got
him almost everybody is out now back
home with their parents their wives
their husbands I want every American to
be prepared for the hard days that lie
ahead we're gonna go through a very
tough two weeks and then hopefully as
the experts are predicting as I think a
lot of us are predicting after having
studied it's so hard
you're gonna start seeing some real
light at the end of the tunnel but this
is going to be a very painful very very
painful two weeks when you look and see
at night the kind of death that's been
caused by this invisible enemy it's it's
incredible I was watching last night
governor Murphy of New Jersey say 29
people died today meaning yesterday and
others talking about numbers far greater
but you get to know a state I know New
Jersey so well and you hit 29 people and
hundreds and other locations hundreds in
other states and this is going to be a
rough two-week period as a nation we
face a difficult few weeks as we
approach that that really important day
when we're going to see things get
better all of a sudden and it's going to
be like a burst of light I really think
and I hope our strength will be tested
and our endurance will be tried but
America will answer with love and
courage and ironclad resolve this is the
time for all Americans to come together
and do our part now I appreciate a lot
of the media we've had a lot of really
good things said I think only good
things can be said when you look at the
job that's been done I've just spoke
with Franklin Graham was an
extraordinary person and Samaritan's
Purse
has been like so many others just been
amazing and so fast they did it so fast
he's been doing that for a long time but
I think people are really seeing what
they have done
Franklin Graham very special family as
we send plane loads of masks and gloves
and supplies to the communities battling
the plague and that's what it is it's a
plague we also send our prayers we pray
for the doctors and the nurses for the
paramedics and the truck drivers and the
police officers and the sanitation
workers and
above all the people fighting for their
lives in New York and all across our
land I watched as doctors and nurses
went into a certain Hospital in Elmhurst
this morning I know Elmhurst Queens
that's I grew up right next to it I know
the hospital very well been saying it
all my life my young life and I will
tell you that to see the scenes of
[Music]
trailers out there and what they're
doing with those trailers their freezers
and nobody could even believe it and I
spoke to some of my friends they can't
believe what they're seeing and I
watched the doctors and the nurses
walking into that Hospital this morning
it's like military people going into
battle going into war the bravery is
incredible and I just have to take my
hat I would take my head if I were
wearing I had I'd ripped that hat off so
fast and I would say you people are just
incredible they really are they're very
brave they're going in and they don't
know you have you have lots of things
flying around in the air you don't know
what you're touching is it safe and you
also see where you have friends that go
into the hospital and you say how how is
he doing two days later and they say sir
he's unconscious or is in a coma so
things are happening that we've never
seen before in this country and with all
of that being said the countries come
together like I've never seen it before
and we will prevail we will win and
hopefully it will be in a relatively
short period of time with that I'd like
to ask dr. Burks to come up and show you
some of the lattice just the data that
has been I think brilliantly put
together and right after that I'm going
to ask dr. Fowler to speak and Mike
Pence is going to
give you some of the recent events that
have taken place and some of the
statistics that we have that I think
will be very interesting here thank you
very much
Thank You mr. president
if I can I have the first slide please
so always and that's what this slide is
labeled is goals of community mitigation
really highlighting that this begins in
the middle and the end with community
this community and the community of the
American people that are going to have
to do the things for the next 30 days to
make a difference I think you know from
that large blue mountain that you can
see behind me and I just want to thank
the five or six international and and
domestic modelers from Harvard from
Columbia from Northeastern from Imperial
who helped us tremendously it was their
models that created the ability to see
what these mitigations could do how
steeply they could depress the curve
from that giant blue mountain down to
that more stippled area in their
estimates they had between 1.5 million
and 2.2 million people in the United
States succumbing to this virus without
mitigation yet through their detailed
studies and showing us what social
distancing would do what people what
would happen if people stayed home what
would happen if people weren't careful
every day to wash their hands and worry
about touching their faces that what an
extraordinary thing this could be if
every American followed these and it
takes us to that stippled mountain
that's much lower a hill actually down
to 100 to 200 thousand deaths which is
still way too much next slide please
simultaneously there was a modeler out
of the University of Washington that
modeled from cases up utilizing the
experience around the globe to really
understand how this information that we
have from Italy
in Spain and South Korea and China could
really help us give insight into the
hospital needs the ventilator needs and
really the the number of people who
potentially could succumb to this
illness it is this model that we are
looking at now that provides us the most
detail of the time course that is
possible but this model assumes full
mitigation it's informed every morning
or every night by the reality on the
ground coming in from New York New
Jersey and around the United States and
is modeled and informed every morning so
that it is adjusted so it is up-to-date
every day this is the model of the
predicted fatalities and mortality in
the United States and as the president
said it's very much focused on the next
two weeks and the stark reality of what
this virus will do as it moves through
communities next slide please
but this is a slide that gives us great
hope and understanding about what is
possible on the bottom of the slide
where you can barely see that blue line
at the very bottom that's the current
cases in California the cumulative cases
in California where they're doing
significant testing the next line up is
Connecticut the orange line is New
Jersey the blue line is New York the
yellow line is Washington we all
remember Washington state it was just a
month ago when they started to have the
issues in Washington State but they
brought together their communities and
their health providers and they put in
strong mitigation methods and testing
and you can see what the result in
Washington State and California is but
without the continuation for the next 30
days anything could change next slide
please
so I'm sure you're interested in seeing
all the states so on this slide is all
50 states and the District of Columbia
but I think it shows in stark
the difference between New York and New
Jersey and other states with similar
populations and urban areas our goal
over the next 30 days is to ensure the
states that you see the 48 across the
bottom maintain this lower level of new
cases with the hope that we don't have
significant outbreaks in other states
and other metro areas as the community
comes together to work together and
ensure that the healthcare providers
around the globe and in the United
States are strengthened by our resolve
to continue to mitigate community by
community this is done community by
community we all know people are in
their states and in their communities
and we're very dependent on each person
in the United States doing the same
thing following the presidential
guidelines to a tee I know it's a lot to
ask because you've done it for 15 days
so if you can show the next slide please
so this is what gives us a lot of hope
this is the case finding in Italy and
you can see that they're beginning to
turn the corner in new cases they're
entering their fourth week of full
mitigation and showing what is possible
when we work together as a community as
a country to change the course of this
pandemic together it is this graphic and
the graphic of many of the states that
gives us hope of what is possible with
continuing for another 30 days amidst
all that hope I must say that like we
warned about Detroit and Chicago we
start to see changes in Massachusetts
New Orleans continues to be a problem of
new cases although they're stabilizing
and I think it really shows the depth of
dedication of the American people to the
health care providers because they can
see the strain that this puts on every
nurse doctor respiratory therapist
pharmacist and laboratory technician
that's working to get
they're to stem this tide of unrelenting
sick people coming to their doors no one
has been turned away
no one who has needed ventilation has
not received ventilation but you can see
how stressful it is on it for each of
them so I know it's stressful to follow
the guidelines but it is more stressful
and more difficult to the soldiers on
the front line as we started and we will
end with it's communities that will do
this there's no magic bullet there's no
magic vaccine or therapy
it's just behaviors each of our behavior
is translating into something that
changes the course of this viral
pandemic over the next 30 days thank you
thank you very much dr. Burks mr.
president mr. vice president
so what dr. Burks has really said very
simply is that there are really two
dynamic forces that are opposing each
other here as I've mentioned several
times in our briefings the virus if left
to its own devices will do that dark
curve that dr. Burks showed you the
other dynamic force is what we are doing
what we're trying to do and what we will
do in the form of mitigation now these
are very revealing bits of data because
you saw what happened in Italy where you
make the turn around the curve and you
go that doesn't happen all at once
it's a stepwise fashion and if I explain
the steps which I will you'll see why we
are really convinced that mitigation is
going to be doing the trick for us
because what you have is you have
increase in new cases at a certain rate
when the increase in new cases begin to
level off the secondary effect is less
hospitalizations the next effect is less
intensive care and the next effect is
less deaths the deaths and the intensive
care and the hospitalization always lag
behind that early indication that there
are less
new cases per day the way we saw in
Italy and the way we're likely seeing I
don't want to jump the gun on it we're
seeing little Inklings of this right now
in New York so what we're gonna see and
that's we gotta brace ourselves in the
next several days to a week or so we're
gonna continue to see things go up
we cannot be discouraged by that because
the mitigation is actually working and
will work the slide that dr. Berg showed
where you saw New York and New Jersey
and then the cluster of other areas our
goal which I believe we can accomplish
is to get the hotspot places the New
York's the New Jersey and help them to
get around that curve but as importantly
to prevent those clusters of areas that
have not yet gone to that spike to
prevent them from getting that spike and
the answer to that is mitigation now the
15 days that we had of mitigation
clearly have had an effect although it's
tough to quantitate it because of those
two opposing forces but the reason why
we feel so strongly about the necessity
of the additional 30 days is that now is
the time whenever you're having an
effect not to take your foot off the
accelerator and on the brake but to just
press it down on the accelerator and
that's what I hope and I know that we
can do over the next 30 days and as I
said the other day and on one of the one
of the interviews we are a very strong
and resilient nation if you look at our
history we've been through some terrible
ordeals this is tough people are
suffering people are dying it's
inconvenient from a societal standpoint
from an economic standpoint to go
through this but this is gonna be the
answer to our problems so let's all pull
together and make sure as we look
forward to the next 30 days we do it
with all the intensity and force that we
can thank you
Thank You mr. president
dr. Burks and dr. Falchi I know I speak
on behalf of the president people all
across this country when I express our
great admiration and appreciation to
both of you for helping to steer our
nation through this challenging time the
American people have now seen what the
president saw when he made the decision
at the end of 15 days to slow the spread
to ask the American people to give us 30
more days to continue to put into
practice the president's coronavirus
guidelines for America and as you just
heard from the experts we have reason to
believe that it's working
dr. Falchi just said there are difficult
days ahead our hearts and our prayers go
out to the families that have lost loved
ones and those as the president says
reflected who we know are struggling at
this hour in hospitals across the nation
but to each and every one of us do not
be discouraged because what you can do
to protect your health the health of
your family what you can do to ensure
that our our health care providers have
the resources and our hospitals have the
capacity to meet this moment is put into
practice the president's coronavirus
guidelines for America it really is what
every American can do 30 days to slow
the spread 30 days to make a difference
in the lives of the American people
American families in the life of our
nation allow me to give you a few brief
updates before the president takes
questions first and foremost we continue
to work very closely with governors
around the nation president I spoke to
all the governors all the states and
territories yesterday and since we were
last together the President and I are
spoken directly and to several
governor's around the country including
Illinois Louisiana Michigan New York and
they're States at the present moment the
president has declared 29 major disaster
declarations and authorized at 10
different states to use full federal
funding so-called title 32 funding to
pay for their National Guard and as of
this afternoon FEMA reports some 17,000
National Guard have been activated in
states around the country to provide
support for coronavirus response on the
subject of testing we have now completed
more than 1.1 million tests around the
country we're working very closely with
governor's around America to to assist
them in drive-thru and community testing
centers I spoke with governor JB
Pritzker of Illinois today about a
testing center that they've established
in cooperation with the US Public Health
Service we remind every governor and
every laboratory and hospital in the
country it's imperative that you
continue to report daily to the CDC the
results of those tests to give us the
visibility on the data to best inform
resource decisions also we we reiterated
today to governor's in person and and
also through correspondence to every
governor the importance of using their
National Guard if need be to move
medical supplies FEMA is very busy as
you'll hear in a moment delivering
literally millions of supplies to states
around the country but we're urging
every governor to make sure to work with
their state emergency management team
and maybe use the National Guard to move
those supplies from warehouses to
hospitals if the president moment as the
president said we've distributed more
than 11.6 million in 95 masks more than
80-100 ventilators around the nation
millions of face shields surgical masks
and gloves we initiated an air bridge
that the president announced yesterday
flights have arrived in New York one
arrived in Illinois yesterday and a
flight will arrive in Ohio in the next
24 hours FEMA is literally working and
contracting around the war
old with now more than 51 flights will
be bringing vital medical supplies on
the subject of ventilators FEMA is
currently delivering 400 ventilators to
Michigan 300 in New Jersey 150 to
Louisiana 50 ventilators to Connecticut
and in the last week and in the week
ahead more than 450 ventilators to
Illinois this is in addition to more
than 4,400 ventilators at the President
and FEMA directed to the state of New
York we just want people that are
working on the front line said the
president just spoke about dr. Burks and
doctor foul she spoke about we want you
to know help is on the way and at the
president's direction we're gonna leave
no stone unturned anywhere in America or
anywhere in the world to make sure that
you have the resources and the equipment
to do your job
so again I want to just say thank you
America thank you for stepping up thank
you for putting into practice the 15
days to slow the spread and thank you
for the response that tens of millions
have already had for the 30 days to slow
the spread we encourage each one of you
as we have governors around the country
to spread the word about the guidelines
listen to your state and local
authorities in areas that are more
greatly impacted we continue to urge
people in the areas of New York New
Jersey and Connecticut to refrain from
travel around the country people who've
traveled from that area check your
temperature and self quarantine for 14
days you can see from that chart the
unique challenges people in the Greater
New York City area are facing with the
coronavirus and we want to do all that
we can to protect your health focus
resources and the community and prevent
unnecessary spread lastly as the
president highlighted yesterday
businesses around America are stepping
up as never before
tomorrow I'll travel with secretary
sonny perdue to Gordonsville Virginia to
the Walmart distribution center just so
the American people can see firsthand
how the food supply is continuing to
roll on 18 wheels and through air
freight all over America and we thank
again the grocery store operators around
the mayor
everybody that's working out on the
highways and byways every day to keep
that food supply rolling and rolling
strong to the American people though we
we just want to assure you that we're
going to continue to work our hearts out
work our hearts out to make sure our
health care providers have everything
they need that anyone struggling with
coronavirus has a sport and health care
they need I'm absolutely confident
seeing the way our governors are
responding seeing this team the
president has assembled in the White
House coronavirus task force confident
of the prayers of the American people
that will get through this but it will
take all of us doing our part and we'll
get through it together just to be clear
what is the projected death toll should
people be reasonably good at following
these mitigation measures good I guess
we could say that I'd like to have maybe
doctor taught you or Deb come up and say
I but I have numbers but I'd rather have
them say the numbers if you don't mind
it's big so of course this is a
projection and it's a projection based
on using very much what's happened in
Italy and then looking at all the models
and so as you saw on that slide that was
our real number without a hundred
thousand to two hundred thousand and we
think that that is the range we really
believe in hope every day that we can do
a lot better than that because that's
not assuming a hundred percent of every
American does everything that they're
supposed to be doing but I think that's
possible next two weeks are going to be
very painful
so as mortality the fatalities to this
disease will increase and then it will
come back down and it will come back
down slower than the rate at which it
went up and so that's that is really the
issue how how much we can push the
mortality down yeah so our hope is to
get that down as far as far as we
possibly can
the modelling that dr. Burke showed
predicts that number that you saw we
don't accept that number that that's
what it's gonna be we're gonna be doing
everything we can to get it even
significantly below that so you know I
don't want it to be a mixed message this
is the thing that we need to anticipate
but that doesn't mean that that's what
we're gonna accept we want to do much
much better than that so we would have
death in cases for much longer I mean we
do expect fly number two so that's a
generic I'm sorry you can go back to the
slides and put a fly - that's okay so
what I showed you was a generic picture
of what happens in an epidemic when you
mitigate so no mitigation mitigate this
is based on the experience around the
globe with this particular virus and so
it does have a tail but the peak you can
see by this projection and this is the
eye hme data the peak is over the next
two weeks and that site and this is
tracking mortality so the number of
fatalities from this virus and so that's
the part that we think we can still
blunt through the superb medical care
that every client is receiving but also
even more stringent people following the
guidelines I can't see the small
characters but are we seeing this until
June I can't really this is June so we
would still see problems and deaths in
June so I mean just getting back to what
I said about the stepwise thing deaths
always lag so you will be seeing deaths
at a time when as an epidemic we're
doing really really well because the
deaths will lag
they prepare for the likelihood that
there will be a hundred thousand
Americans who die from this virus the
answer is yes we need as sobering a
number as that is we should be prepared
for it is it going to be that much I
hope not and I think the more we push on
the mitigation the less likelihood it
would be that number but as being
realistic we need to prepare ourselves
that that is a possibility that that's
what was a short period of time for that
to happen but can the country handle
that in such a short period of time
within a couple of months you know a
month you know it will be difficult I
mean no one is denying the fact that we
are going through a very very difficult
time right now I mean we're seeing
what's happening in New York that is
really really tough and if you
extrapolate that to the nation that will
be really tough but that's what it is
Jim and we're gonna have to be prepared
for that
that model that was from I hme that's
based and heavily laden by the data that
has come in from New York and New Jersey
and Connecticut so you know that can
skew to a higher peak and more
significant mortality if all of the
other states are able and I all the
other metro areas are able to hold that
case number down then it's a very
different picture but you have to
predict on the data you have which is
heavily skewed to New York and New
Jersey getting back to that that's
really an important slide that dr. Burke
showed the cluster of other cities that
are not New York and not New Jersey if
we can suppress that from any kind of a
spike the numbers could be significantly
lower than what we're talking about
we're not following these guys well and
that's the reason my plea at the end of
my remarks Jim that now is the time to
put your foot on the accelerator because
that's the only thing that's gonna stop
those piece
some of the cities are doing very well
as you see very well at this early stage
just go yeah one more slide would you
talk about
would you tell cities that aren't doing
what you know New York New Jersey
Washington you know the cities that have
been taking charge in all of this would
you urge some of the cities that haven't
been doing this mr. president to get
with the program
why would you see so much harder time
than other of the cities certain cities
of doing actually they were early but
we're seeing the places in Florida not
doing what New York New Jersey has been
doing what Washington State has been
that we think very well with the
question to you and then to dr. Falchi
as well we you told us yesterday that
your accomplishment of the u.s. at least
is accomplishing a hundred thousand
tests per day but we're still hearing
difficult stories from the front lines
of the first responders do you praise so
appropriately a little while ago but
they can't test all of the people that
they need to test do you have any kind
of projection as to when everyone who
needs a test will be able to receive
yeah I can only say that we're doing
more than anybody in the world by far we
are testing highly accurate tests is a
test that work as you know many tests
are being sent to countries they're
broken well we're doing every day we get
and the word is exponential we are
getting more and more and more and now
we have the new test that you saw
yesterday that's going to be rolled out
I think tomorrow or the next day and
that's going to take only a few minutes
literally a few minutes to see the
result and it's a highly accurate result
I mean
the tests were given out not by us by
other countries where there was a 50/50
chance that it was wrong what kind of a
test is that these are highly accurate
tests but the new tests that are coming
out are very quick and they were just
developed Abbott Labs did the one
yesterday so we're doing more than
anybody in the world by far and they're
very accurate tests and we're getting a
lot of information from those tests the
test president unveiled yesterday the
Abbott Laboratories test which is a 15
minute test our team is working very
closely with Andrews raw and FEMA to
make sure that those are distributed
around around the country earlier this
week Abbott Laboratories actually going
to be producing 50,000 tests a day and
distributing those around America
there's already the machines in some
18,000 different locations around the
country and they've told us they have
several thousand on the shelf now and
what we're doing is trying to identify
the areas where we may yet have pockets
or as dr. Burks often says we're where
we want to do more immediate testing so
that we can do what's called
surveillance testing to identify where
where there may be coronavirus cases
where there's been very little incident
but if I could just amplify one other
point and that is that when you look at
this chart go back 15 days and the
reality is that and this is me speaking
as a layperson but as I've listened to
our experts in New York and the Greater
New York City area have unique
challenges it's a it's a city that we we
really believe may have had exposure to
the corona virus much earlier on then
and we could have known and had its own
challenges in New York Connecticut New
Jersey are leaning into this effort but
when when we look at this chart for all
the other states including Washington
state in California it really does give
evidence that at least it begins to give
evidence that the 15 days to slow the
spread is working and then in fact the
American people are putting these things
into practice in states across the con
including in New York and New Jersey
even though they've they faced a greater
magnitude of cases for certain
circumstances that are related to
international travel in those
communities but anything national
shelter-in-place
what I'd suggest to you Jim is the
American people can look at these
numbers in the other 48 states and they
can see that in the last 15 days the
president's coronavirus guidelines were
working that's precisely why president
Trump is asking every American to
continue to put these guidelines into
practice for 30 more days so right now
we're at about 4,000 deaths here the
United States you suggesting they spiked
of more than 90,000 deaths over the next
few weeks do you have a demographic
breakdown of the areas that are most at
risk and where most of those deaths may
occur well right now and I think if you
ask Chris Murray he would say he's using
the information coming out of New York
and New Jersey and applying that to
potentially other states having the same
outcomes I just want to say again this
yellow line there's a yellow line and
this is all corrected for a hundred
thousand residents so this is normalized
so we can compare apples to apples
Washington State so they've been able to
for a long time of measuring cases not
have a spike so it's possible and we're
watching very closely to make sure it
doesn't have a spike but that's what the
people in Washington state are doing
this is what every community so it
Washington State early about two weeks
before New York or New Jersey California
a week before New York or New Jersey
really talked to their communities and
decided to mitigate before they started
seeing this number of cases and now we
know that that makes a big difference
early as dr. Falchi said if you wait
till you see it it's too late you have a
demographic breakdown dr.
where these decima occur so there's a
Democrat deaf demographic breakdown that
we've discussed before related to
mortality and it's as we're seeing in
New York exactly what we saw in Italy
very low mortality not to say that young
people under 30 or young people under 40
aren't getting ill they are but most of
them are recovering so the profile looks
identical to Italy with increasing
mortality with age and pre-existing
medical conditions and so that is
holding in the same way but what we're
hoping is that through the work of
communities and again it comes down to
communities this is not this is
communities deciding that this is
important to them to not have the
experience of New York and New Jersey
and I think you know we are worried
about groups all around the globe I mean
I don't know if you heard the report
this morning there's 8,000 ventilators
in the UK if you translate that to
United States that would be like the
United States having less than 40,000
ventilators we have five times that
amount so I mean these are the things
that everybody is having to face and I
think the United States is in an
excellent position from our medical care
position but we don't want to have to
test that system we want this to be a
much smaller epidemic with much smaller
mortality real quick before we move on
so so the testing numbers I understand a
million tests done it's a big increase
but we were told there would be 27
million tests available by the end of
the month so can you outline we're in
the supply chain we're in the logistics
chain are those other 26 you know where
are the other 26 million tests right I
think this is just for purposes of
clarifications there's a difference
between sending a test that can be
administered to a test being done and
because a month ago or more the
president brought together the top
commercial labs in America and said we
need you to partner with us to to create
a brand new system that would rapidly
process tests we're now at 1.1 million
tests and we believe it's a fair
estimate that we're testing about a
hundred thousand Americans a day that'll
continue to grow it'll continue to
accelerate but I think that the
misunderstanding early on was there were
many tests being distributed many test
kits being sent but under the old system
as the presidents described it the
antiquated system those were being
processed in in state labs or at CDC or
in private labs on a very slow
methodical a system that could only
produce maybe 30 to 50 tests a day but
this new partnership that we have with
commercial laboratories allows the
progress we're making
but the breakthrough with Abbott
Laboratories now moves to point-of-care
which means you're going to have devices
and tests that people will literally be
able to take at their doctor's office at
a hospital at a clinic at a nursing home
and have the results in 15 minutes so
there's a twenty six million tests we
were talking about were those tests
under the old antiquated system now so
are we still even using those those
twenty seven million tests or have we
just completely moved on to the point
answer is yes even today which is I have
to say coming out of laboratories and
developed tests and worked on vaccines
and I've gone to the field to actually
combat epidemics it is disappointing to
me right now that we have about 500,000
capacity of Abbott
that are not being utilized so they are
out there in the states they're not
being run and not utilized so now we
have to figure out how do we create
awareness because sometimes when you put
an early platform out like our first
platform out when the high speed was
Roche so you get that out people get
dependent on that and then don't see
that there's availability of other tests
so right now there's over a half a
million tests sitting capacity that are
not being utilized so we're trying to
figure out how do we inform States about
where these all are how do we work
through every laboratory Association so
they're aware and how do we raise
awareness so people know that there's
point of care
there's thermo Fisher there's Abbot
testing and there's Roche and if you add
those together that's millions of tests
a week or they're not even being used so
that's what's really so that's what
we're working on because when people get
used to a single platform they keep
sending it back to that lab so it's
getting in a queue to wait to get on a
Roche machine rather being moved to this
other lab that may have Abbott capacity
because they're all in different
laboratories and so I think well
actually Admiral girar is figuring it
out to really create some kind of visual
so that every governor and every Health
Commissioner can see all of their
capacity in their countries I mean in
their states county-by-county so that
they know where the tests are so we
pushed a lot of tests out but they're
not all being utilized dr. Burks
explained it very very well I just want
to get back John to your question it's a
logical question when you look at the
number you want to know what the
demography is going to be this is a
number that we need to anticipate but we
don't necessarily have to accept that as
being inevitable and that's getting back
to what I'm saying
about we can influence this to a varying
degrees and if we influence it to the
maximum we don't have to accept that
that's something we need to anticipate
but I want to do not
I all of us want to do much much better
than that what are the models suggest
he's on the low end if you have full
mitigation well it says it's a hundred
to two hundred thousand anything which a
lot of people write it's a lot of people
well you didn't ask the other question
what would have happened because this is
the question that I've been asking dr.
Falchi and dr. Brooks for a long time
and they've been working on this for a
long time the question is what would
have happened if we did nothing because
there was a group that said let's just
write it out let's write it out what
would have happened and that number
comes in at 1.5 to 1.6 million people up
to 2.2 and even beyond so that's 2.2
million people would have died if we did
nothing we just carried on our life now
I don't think that would have been
possible because you would have had
people dying all over the place this
would not have been a normal life how
many people have even seen anybody die
you would have seen people dying on
airplanes you would have been seeing
people dying in hotel lobbies you would
have seen death all over so I think from
a practical standpoint that couldn't
have been carried out too far but but if
you if you did nothing on the higher
side the number would be 2.2 and maybe
even more and on the lower side 1.6
million people 100,000 is the number
with full mitigation so John it's an
obvious very good question
if this is full mitigating mitigation
and it's a hundred thousand why am i
standing there saying I want to make it
better because that's what the model
tells you what's going to do what we do
is that every time we get more data you
feed it back in and relook at the model
is the model really telling you what's
actually going on and again I know my
modeling colleagues are gonna not be
happy with me but models are as good as
the assumptions you put into them and as
we get more data then you put it in and
that
I change so even though it says
according to the model which is a good
model that we're dealing with this is
full mitigation as we get more data as
the week's go by that could be modified
why does the model now the top line on
the lowball estimate why does that not
talk about it I think it's a 240,000 not
two hundred thousands that it changed
that because the states haven't been
doing enough you know it just has to do
with if you had more New York's and New
Jersey's you know its ACOG Oh Detroit LA
Dallas Houston you know all of our major
cities modeled like New York that's what
gets us into trouble but I am reassured
by looking at the Seattle line by
looking at the LA line by looking at
what California has been able to do that
that is not something that I don't
believe that's gonna happen that is the
outside case of having 1015 metros like
New York and the New Jersey metro area
New York had community spread pretty
early undetected so don't many of those
other states if not more of them okay
even less information
aren't they likely to see the same spike
well California and Washington state
reacted very early to this I
yes Washington State had some of the
earliest infections they have kept it
low and steady and for now a month has
been tracking it with a small increase
in the number of cases but not this
logarithmic form of the virus and so
that's the that's the piece that we're
trying to prevent that's the piece that
we're trying to prevent in New Orleans
in Detroit in Chicago and in Boston
right now and and trying to make sure
that each of those cities work more like
California than the New York metro area
mr. president I just wanted to get your
thoughts on face masks
asked you about this yesterday and you
signaled you were thinking about it
because I think I could say this to dr.
Burks before and to dr. Frenchy for
whatever reason New York got off to a
very late start and we see what happens
when you get off to a late start New
Jersey get off and I think both
governors are doing an excellent job but
they got off to a very late start when
you look at Washington State if you
remember that all started in a very
confined nursing home and you had 20
some-odd people I believe dying in one
home that doesn't mean it escaped that
home and so they have a very different
statistic than other states but I mean I
remember it very vividly the nursing
home and in Washington state where you
had many people dying every day people
were dying in the one exact location so
they were able to keep that relatively
speaking into that location when you see
a hundred thousand people that said and
that's at a minimum number now what
we're looking at and as many people as
we're talking about whatever we can do
under that number and substantially
under that number we've done that
through really great mitigation we've
done that through a lot of very
dedicated American people that you know
a hundred thousand is is according to
modeling a very low number in fact that
when I first saw the number and I asked
this a while ago they said it's unlikely
you'll be able to attain that I think
we're doing better that now I think we
have to see but I think we're doing
better than that because as John said
that would be you know a lot of lives
taking place over a relatively short
period of time but think of what would
have happened if we didn't do anything I
mean I've had many friends
businesspeople people with great
actually common sense they said what are
we right at a lot of people have said a
lot of people have thought about it
write it out don't do anything just
write it out and think of it as the flu
but it's not
it's vicious when you send a friend to
the hospital and you call up to find out
how is he doing it happened to me where
goes to the hospital he says goodbye
sort of a tough guy a little older a
little heavier then he'd like to be
frankly and you go up the next day how's
he doing and he's in a coma this is not
the flu so we would have seen things had
we done nothing but for a long while a
lot of people were asking that question
I think right I was asking that also I
mean a lot of people were saying well
let's just write it out this is not to
be written out because then you would
have been looking at potentially 2.2
million people or more 2.2 million
people in a relatively short period of
time if you remember they were looking
at that concept it's a concept I guess
you know what's concept if you if you
don't mind death a lot of death but they
were looking at that in the UK remember
they were very much looking at it and
all of a sudden they went hard the other
way because they started seeing things
that weren't good so they they were you
know they put themselves in a little bit
of a problem now Boris tested positive
and I hear he's hope he's going to be
fine but in the UK they were looking at
that and they have a name for it but we
won't even call we won't even go by the
name but it would have been it would
have been very catastrophic I think if
that would have happened but that was
something that everybody was talking
about safe like just don't do anything
don't do anything forget about
everything just write it up they use the
expression write it out we would have
had at a minimum 1.5 1.6 but you would
have had perhaps more than 2.2 million
people dying in a very short period of
time and that would have been a number
that the likes of which we've never seen
so now when we look at our package that
we just approved for two trillion
dollars all of a sudden it seems very
reasonable right when you're talking
about two million lives all of a sudden
it seems very reasonable I must say a
lot of people that have been
seeing the more advanced numbers because
these are much more advanced numbers now
you know when you first started we
didn't know and this was a different
kind of a virus and nobody knew that
much about it even the experts you don't
really know where it's going but then
they see what goes on in Italy and they
see what goes on in Spain and you see
France is having a very hard time and
other countries having a very very hard
time but once they see what's going on
they start making projections so I hope
they gotta be very high projections but
based on everything else that would be
the number let's see if we can do much
better than that I hope we can you know
you can use a scarf scarf is everybody a
lot of people have scarfs and you can
use a scarf scarf would be very good and
my my feeling is if people want to do it
there's certainly no harm to it I would
say do it but use a scarf if you want
you know rather than going out and
getting a mask or whatever we're making
millions and millions of masks but we
want them to go to the hospitals I mean
one of the things that doctor foul she
told me today is we don't want them
competing we don't want everybody
competing with the hospitals where you
really need them so you can use scarfs
you can use something else over your
face it doesn't have to be a mask but
it's not a bad idea at least for a
period of time I mean eventually you're
not gonna want to do that you're not
gonna have to do that this is going to
be gone it'll be gone hopefully gone for
a long time is that enough we hope it's
enough we hope it's enough we hope we're
at a level where we could say let's go
because our country wants to get back to
work we really want to get back
everybody wants to get back to work now
I could ask the doctors to answer that
question but we discussed that all the
time what do you think
recommending harsher well I think I
think we've been very harsh I mean you
look at the streets I looked at Fifth
Avenue today on camera and I didn't see
anybody walking on the street and I'm
used to watching that Street you can't
even see you can't see the asphalt you
can't see the concrete and you look at
this nobody there was one car it looked
like it might have been a taxicab and it
was in a time of the morning then
normally there'd be a lot of people i
mean you know i think i think the
mitigation has been very strong please
mr. president will you confirm your
plans to defer tariff payments for 90
days and secondly on it I didn't I
didn't do anything about I don't know
who's talking about tariff payments they
keep talking about tariff payments and
we haven't done that China's paying us
we made a deal with China under the deal
they're paying us 25 percent on two
hundred and fifty billion dollars and
they pay it and I spoke with President
Xi the other day and he didn't mention
that we didn't mention that we had a
great conversation by the way a really
productive conversation having to do
with many things most of it was on the
virus but you know we're not talking to
who you were who you were if I can just
clarify for us Wall Street drone
reporting by The Wall Street Journal
Bloomberg that there's a plan of motion
well they might be but I'm gonna have to
approve the plan one thing I will tell
you I approve everything and they
haven't presented it to me so therefore
it's false reporting so therefore don't
do the story if we're going to do
something I'd be glad to let you know
there's nothing wrong with doing it but
well let you know yeah please look a
couple of back there we'll get back to
you okay thanks politics I wanted to ask
you about individual states issuing stay
at home or what do you think for
instance in Florida Rhonda Sanders has
resisted urges to issue one of those but
he said moments ago that if you and the
rest of the task force recommended one
that would weigh on him heavily
what sort of circumstances need to be in
place for you to
make that call I'd say this is something
you chickens a different kind of a state
also great governor knows exactly what
he's doing has a very strong view on it
and we have spoken to run Mike you want
to just tell him a little bit about that
well let me echo our appreciation for
Governor De Santis leadership in Florida
he's been taking decisive steps from
early on and working closely with our
team at the federal level but let me be
very clear on this the recommendation of
our health experts was to take the 15
days to slow the spread and have the
president extend that to 30 days for
every American now that being said we
recognize that that when you're dealing
with a health crisis in the country it
is it is locally executed by health care
workers but it's state managed and so we
continue to flow information to state
governor's we continue to hear about the
the data that they're analyzing and
consult with them but at the president's
Direction the White House coronavirus
task force will continue to take the
posture that we will defer to state and
local health authorities on any measures
that they deem appropriate but for the
next 30 days this is what we believe
every American in every state should be
doing at a minimum to slow the spread we
see something obviously wrong now it's
obviously wrong I mean people can make
things they can make a decision that we
think is so far out that it's wrong we
will stop that but in the case of
governor to scientists you know there's
two thoughts to it and two very good
thoughts to it and he's been doing a
great job in every respect so we'll see
what happens but we only would exercise
if we thought somebody was very
obviously go ahead your turn Thanks
the National Street stockpile but while
you're at the podium I want to ask about
your call with President Putin a couple
days ago I know a big economic concern
for a lot of people in the state of oil
prices right now yeah so I'm wondering
if you raised that with President Putin
if you were able to did and he had it
was probably about that - the oil prices
because as you know Russia and Saudi
Arabia going at it and they're really
going at it and by going at it to the
extent that they are the oil has dropped
to a point where I look it's the
greatest tax cut we've ever given if you
look at it that way because people are
gonna be paying 99 cents for a gallon of
gasoline it's incredible in a lot of
ways it's gonna help the airlines but at
the same time it's hurtful - one of our
biggest industries that's the oil
industry it's really it's not even
feasible what's going on so I spoke to
President Putin about that I also spoke
to the crown prince about that Saudi
Arabia know I think yeah they're gonna
get together and we're all gonna get
together and we're gonna see what we can
do because you don't want to lose an
industry you're gonna lose an industry
over thousands and thousands of jobs we
have I don't know if you know there's
oil all over the oceans right now the
boats are all filled the ships are
they're renting ships ships that were
dying that weren't doing well and now
like their that's where they're storing
oil and they're sent out to sea and they
sit there for long periods of time
there's so much oil in some cases it's
it's probably less valuable than water
in some parts of the world water is much
more valuable so we've never seen
anything like it but the two countries
are discussing it and I am joining at
the appropriate time if need be we had a
great talk with President Putin we had a
great talk with the crown prince
we also discussed more so with President
Putin in this case the virus because
Russia is being hit pretty hard
and we discussed many things trade we
discussed a lot of things with both but
in the case of both we very much
discussed the oil in the oil prices I
mean you look it's $22 but it's really
much cheaper than that if you want to
negotiate nobody seen that that's like
from the 1950s it really is you know to
think that it was 50 60 70 80 and now
it's 22 but you know if you put a good
bit in at 9 I think you could probably
get what you wanted right John please
mr. president yeah we you tweeted
earlier today that now would be a good
time to start looking for if there is a
light at the end of the tunnel and work
on an infrastructure bill again you
suggest that it should be 2 trillion
dollars which is twice what the last one
was or the proposal released are you
anticipating that like after the
economic crisis of 2008 2009 America
will need to have so-called shovel ready
jobs ready to go to get people back to
work well the problem with that one is
they had maybe shovel-ready jobs and
maybe not but they never used it for the
purpose of infrastructure so far nobody
has been able to find any money that was
spent on infrastructure I want to use it
for infrastructure and one of the
reasons I'm suggesting at John is who
are paying zero interest the United
States is paying almost zero interest
rate the Federal Reserve lowered the
rate the Fed rate and that and a
combination of the fact that everybody
wants to be in the United States you
know we have the $1 that's very strong
and I know that sounds good but it does
make it hard to manufacture and sell
outside because other currencies are
falling in our currency is very strong
it's very very strong proportionately
it's through the roof so we have a
strong dollar people want to invest in
the United States especially nowadays
where they're looking at safety they
have all of the problems plus the virus
at 151 countries they all want to come
into the United States and so we have a
zero interest rate essentially and I
said wouldn't this be a great time to
borrow money at zero interest rate and
really build our infrastructure like we
can do it so the plan was the
Republicans had a plan of about 750 I
would say they were we're at 75 what you
had the Democrats were a little less
than a trillion dollars
Republicans were a little bit less than
that and I'm suggesting two trillion
dollars we redo our roads our highways
our bridges we fix up our tunnels which
are many of them in bad shape like
coming into New York as you know a
really bad shape and we really do a job
on our infrastructure and that doesn't
mean we're gonna do the green new deal
because I won't do it I want to prove it
we're not gonna do the green new deal
and to spend you know 40 percent of the
money and things that people just have
fun with the money at zero percent
Interest so our interest payments would
be almost zero and we can borrow long
term people want to be in the United
States they want to be invested in the
United States go ahead Jim I want to get
back to the virus you were saying at the
beginning of the press conference that
you're looking at holding back 10,000
ventilators is that because you need to
pick and choose where these ventilators
are going to have to go because of the
nature of the pandemic why she's running
and also I just want as dr. Falchi and
dr. Burks if it's possible after you
finished is that part of the reason why
you're projecting a hundred thousand to
two hundred thousand deaths that there
going to be some people who aren't going
to be able to get ventilators actually
has the opposite because we're holding
back we have almost 10,000 and we're
holding because we're gonna need them
over the next couple of weeks as this
surge goes on you see that you're we
haven't hit the top yet and we have to
be able to move them immediately and we
can't take them because it's going to be
very hard to do that we can't take them
to places that aren't needing them plus
we have requests for ventilators in
hospitals and in states and cities that
don't need them in our opinion they
don't need them they won't need them at
the top so we're holding it back for
flexibility we actually just took 600
and we sent them to different locations
today but we have close to 10,000 and
we'll be able to get them and we're all
set to March we have the National
Guard's and we have FEMA and we're all
set to move them to the places so as for
your second question what we're going to
do is save lives because of it because
otherwise we would not be able to get to
the events and we don't know what the
hottest bodies
right now in some areas we might but
we've done a great job with ventilators
and we're having a maid unbelievable we
have now 11 companies making ventilators
now they'll be starting to arrive in the
next week but we've also grabbed a lot
of them some hospitals had more than
they were saying or at least more than
we knew about which is a good thing not
a bad thing but we want to be able to
have I guess the word would be
flexibility so that if the surge turns
out to be much stronger in Louisiana
which it could that we can immediately
bring a thousand or two thousand to
Louisiana otherwise we wouldn't be able
to get him we wouldn't be able to say
listen
Governor Cuomo in New York we want to
take ventilators are away from New York
and they'll say well we can't do that it
would be a disaster so we have great
flexibility now when the surge occurs if
it occurs fairly evenly we'll be able to
distribute them very quickly before they
need them but we want to have we have a
reserve right now it's like having oil
reserves except more valuable frankly
but we have a reserve right now and
we'll be able and we also have a great
team of people ready to deliver they can
move them fast so when we see it going
up in a certain state and Louisiana
could be one and Michigan could be
another with Detroit because Detroit is
having a lot of a lot of hard time right
there Detroit came out of nowhere and
that's what happens with this it comes
out of nowhere so we are ready Jim
depending on what happens and we have a
stockpile and that's why it's called a
stockpile now a lot of the ventilators
and a lot of the other equipment rather
than sending it to the stockpile we had
it sent directly to a hospital to a
location to a place so we didn't have
the cumbersome nature of having it come
in unboxed put it and then deliver it we
have it brought which they've never done
before they don't do that generally
speaking they don't do that but we've
had I think Mike we've had tremendous
success at doing that that's four other
items including ventilators where it's
brought to the site that needs it but we
have a good supply of ventilators and
we're ready to go we're all ready we
have trucks ready we have everything
ready because as we're saying John this
could
be a hell of a bad two weeks this is
gonna be a very bad two and maybe even
three weeks this is going to be three
weeks like we haven't seen before well I
think the hospitals are going to be
facing a war so and that's what it is
I've heard I've heard some of the
paramedics and some of the doctors they
said they were they've been in war zones
they've been it they've never seen
anything like this you look at Elmhurst
Hospital in Queens I've never seen I
mean I look I just think it's so because
that's a hospital that's near where I
grew up and it's it is a war zone in a
true sense you up on the ventilator so
we've been hearing from governors who
say they are fighting amongst themselves
essentially bidding amongst themselves
you're doing if that happens they should
be calling us look we have ventilators
but we've distributed thousands of
ventilators but they shouldn't be doing
that
and if they need them that badly we know
we have pretty good ideas of where
they're going to need them some people
frankly think they need them and they
don't need them I don't want to mention
names but there are some people that
want them and it's really not the right
thing then you have some people that I
guess automatically hoard a little bit
they want to have more than they think
they need but you know a ventilator is a
very precious piece of equipment right
now it's hard to make it takes a long
time to make it it's complex some of
them are like the dashboard of an
airplane I mean they're very complicated
and very expensive machines and some are
much simpler but we're ready to go
depending on what happens but we have
some hospitals in some states that think
they need ventilators and we don't think
they do now if they do need them we will
have them there before they need them
we'll be able to move very quickly
data on these trials nothing that I've
heard I mean that's the first question I
make every morning I tell you I call up
you know we have 1100 1100 in New York
right now and we have other locations
where there where patients people are
taking them now the good news is it's
only three days and you know it's like a
seven or eight day treatment the good
news is we haven't heard anything bad in
other words there's no catastrophic
events but we haven't it's a little bit
too soon to talk about it it would be a
total GameChanger John if that happened
if that happened it would be a
game-changer and we include that in that
and I think in all cases the z-pak
you know what the z-pak is so we're
gonna see what happens with the hydroxy
chloroquine some show promise I think
maybe the doctor might want to speak
about the vaccines because a lot of
Johnson & Johnson is advanced very
advanced we'll see what happens the one
thing with a vaccine is you it doesn't
help this group because this group it's
you know you need to test a vaccine the
one thing with the drug you just
mentioned right is that that's been out
it's a malaria drug and also an
arthritis drug so it's been out there
for one kind of very powerful drug but
it's been out there for a long time so
it's tested in the sense that you know
it doesn't kill you but you may want to
discuss the vaccines for a second dr.
Graham thank thank you mr. president but
just for a second before the vaccine and
answered your question Steve there are a
number of candidates the the drugs that
are now being looked at in various ways
either compassionate use clinical trials
are generally drugs that already exist
for other things there's a whole menu of
drugs and interventions that are now
going into clinical trials that are not
approved for anything yet I mean for
example things like immune serum
convalescent plasma or hyper
immunoglobulin or monoclonal antibodies
a variety of other things right now
there's a lot of activity going on
behind the scenes in the design of the
kinds of clinical trials that will give
us an answer because you need an answer
because if it doesn't work you want to
get it off the table and go to the next
one so there are a lot of things
vaks know it takes at least months at
least months at least so I mean that's
the reason why you're seeing a lot of
activity with drugs that already exists
for other purposes because they're
already there but the drugs that you
want to show in a good randomized
clinical trial had very best they're
going to take months just one word in
the vaccine
you know exactly like we said we hope
that as we get into the summer if in
fact there are cases out there when
you're in a phase 2 or phase 3 trial or
two to be as we call it that we might
get an early efficacy signal and an
efficacy signal means that even though
you haven't definitively proven that a
vaccine works you get enough information
that if it were an emergency you might
be able to have an emergency use
authorization for hydroxychloroquine and
as if ramai s'en which is you know you
take it with it maybe if you want for
the infection I think some medical
workers are doing that using it maybe
we're getting it prescribed perhaps us
for another use but the word is that
some are and some are I mean I think
it's not a bad idea
to do it but that's up to the doctors
but there is a a theory going around
that in our country and some other
countries people are taking that to work
in the hospitals that work with the
patient's because there is some evidence
and again it's gonna have to be proven
it's very early you know we're rushing
this stuff through it was supposed to
take a long time to be approved and I
prevailed upon the FDA to get it
approved immediately on the basis that
it was already in the market for a lot
of years for another years malaria
mostly and arthritis but mostly malaria
so we'll see what happens but there is a
theory out there that for the medical
worker the doctor it may work
you take it it's you know it's been out
there for a long time please go ahead go
back to Jim's question about the
national stockpile but the governor
anacott know which the stricken
stockpile governor of Connecticut today
said that he was disturbed to learn that
the stockpile was now empty that's his
words and he said well it's not empty
let me explain something what we doing I
thought I said it accurately I certainly
meant to rather than having it brought
into the stockpile where appropriate
other than certain things like we have
quite a few of the ventilators which is
not a lot when you look at the whole
country actually it sounds like a lot
almost ten thousand but we're trying to
have supply sent directly to the states
because we save a big state we save a
big we don't want medical supplies
coming in to warehouses all over the
place and then we take them from there
and bring them to another warehouse so
we're having it brought from the men
ideally from the manufacturer directly
to the hospital or the state where it's
going so we're trying to keep it that
way as much as possible now in some
cases we are having it brought remember
this we also took over a virtually empty
and I say it again just like we had no
ammunition in the military and we had
virtually no ammunition well we had very
little in medical supplies to in our
stockpile so for the most part we're
trying very hard to have it delivered to
the site where they need it yeah please
go ahead here in the United States
domestically we can practice social
distancing but some of our sailors
specifically on the USS Roosevelt
they're not able to hear they're in
confined spaces what are your thoughts
on that should they be offloaded and
then sir are you concerned I'm going to
let the military ministers but are you
concerned about US military readiness
during this pandemic for instance what
would happen if if as reported China was
to increase patrols in the South China
Sea
what would your well you see all about
that don't worry about our military you
know you said the military put up a
hospital in three and a half days with
beds with a lot of bits nobody has ever
seen anything like it and by the way
that wasn't the only one it wasn't just
a Javits Center it was at other
locations and now it's Louisiana and now
it's New Jersey and now it's other
places one thing that I think is
indisputable is when I watched the Army
Corps of Engineers and FEMA working with
them but when I watched the Army Corps
of Engineers throw up these hospitals
and they're complex I mean these are
incredible buildings essentially tents
and various things but they did it in
such a quick such a short period of time
and our military is ready like you
haven't seen and you know the best the
best guests are the different shows are
we watch the shows at night and I think
the best guests that I've seen in a long
time with the military people and
they've never done it before
I've watched general semi knight who I
deal with a lot
they say Jerry you got to give us two
new hospitals in Louisiana yes sir and
next morning they're building them at
six o'clock in the morning and they're
up in two three days I think they're the
best the best guests you have I guess
I'm tired of the other guests this may
be an uncomfortable question but what
would the models have look like that dr.
Burks and doctor that shows if we
started the social distancing guidelines
sooner in February or January when China
South Korea worth doing this I'm gonna
let them answer what we're getting from
them but if we had started these
practices sooner could these models be
different I'm gonna let him answer the
question but remember this and again I
say it and everybody says it you know it
says it better than anybody is dr.
Falchi I had a decision to make maybe it
was my biggest decision China was
heavily infected and thousands and
thousands of people were coming from
China to the United States and against
the wishes not even wishes but they
disagreed with the decision I made a
decision to stop China from coming in
took a lot of heat even from China they
weren't exactly happy I just made a
trade deal a big one
two hundred and fifty billion dollar
trade deal and I'm shortly thereafter
saying you can't come into our country
that was a big decision that was earlier
than the dates you're talking about so
that was a big decision that was
probably and by the way not because I
did it that was probably the biggest
decision we made so far but if you look
at the one graph the problem New York
has is New York started late but the
other ones didn't start so late now New
York is also more complicated because
you know for obvious reasons but it got
a late start but do you want to maybe
answer those questions because I wanted
to explain two things that I think it's
really important because we had a lot of
questions about mortality and what it
meant so here's the line this is where
we have the ability so you have a large
confidence interval around the line and
so we're trying to move that gray down
tighter and below the dotted line so I
think that's really important and then
if you can go to the next slide so we
really can't answer your question until
we can get antibody testing out there
because what we can't tell you is it and
we can always do this there's always
samples and hospitals and other things
it's the way we really define the HIV
epidemic in the United States we were
able to go back to blood samples when we
had the test and really find out where
it was and what was going on we really
need to look and really see was their
virus significantly circulating in early
March and in late February and what did
it look like and where was it and was it
all in the metro areas and I think
that's what dr. Fauci and I are very
very focused on is getting serology
testing out there to really figure out
when it came and really have those
samples to be able to do that painful
part of my question and
please I don't mean to put you on this
again saying if we had started this
sooner we might not have a hundred
thousand to two hundred thousand
Americans dying well that makes an
assumption there was a lot back here
that we didn't see and until we have the
antibody test I can't really answer that
just what dr. Burks was saying if there
was no virus in the background there was
nothing to mitigate if there was virus
there that we didn't know about then the
answer to your question is probably yes
now the only trouble with that is that
whenever you come out and say something
like that it always becomes almost a
sign sound bite that gets taken out of
context but I think that's very
important what dr. Burks has said is
that if there was covert infections here
that there was virtually nothing there
then there's nothing to mitigate and I I
don't know the answer to question but we
were watching South Korea excuse me in
China and Italy and we weren't taking
action when those countries were
fighting in a perfect world that would
have been nice to know what was going on
there we didn't but I believe Jim that
we reacted very very early in that
adequate testing
can I can I speak to that too as well
president made reference in fact January
31 he suspended all travel from China
shortly thereafter we issued strong
travel advisories for the sections of
Italy implicated in sections of South
Korea and we reached agreements with
those countries to screen all passengers
from all airports coming in to the
United States of America the president's
initial efforts were designed at
preventing the corona virus from coming
into the United States and what our
experts have told us again and again at
the coronavirus task force is that those
actions bought us a significant amount
of time on this curve to respond with
the kind of mitigation efforts standing
up resources testing and supplies that
are in effect but we we went from a
prevention strategy the president acted
on before the month of January was over
to a mitigation strategy which continues
to this day and and if I can also say
just just to every American all the
questions about resources are very
important and I can assure you that the
president and our task force are
preoccupied with these issues and
working with governor's hour by hour to
meet those needs but if Americans will
put into practice these guidelines for
another 30 days they'll do their part to
lower the curve and in save lives most
importantly and limit the burden on our
hospitals and our health care system in
the country significantly and so make no
mistake about it well well we're going
to work our hearts out leave no stone
unturned to find the resources the masks
the ventilators that we need and we are
going to meet that moment with the full
energy of the American economy and the
whole of the American government the
American people have a role to play in
preserving that medical capacity in a
way that will ensure that people that
are caught up in the coronavirus
particularly those that are
vulnerable to the most serious outcomes
which are seniors with serious
underlying health conditions or anyone
with an immunodeficiency have the
resources of sport and the health care
that every American family would want
their loved one to have also think that
we were very smart because we stopped
China we had never done that before
you know we had never closed our borders
before as I read I read other oh maybe
that's not right and doctor foul she had
also said that was a I was I think it
was maybe the biggest moment because we
were stopping the source we were
stopping the infection but we also
stopped Europe very shortly thereafter
that was a big decision that was not an
easy decision either I stopped them a
long time before people started so we
stopped we stopped all of Europe and
then ultimately we how many is an FDA
decision that really depends on a
variety of factors but I would like to
see a clinical trial that has a
comparison to something that is
comparable to what it means without the
drug I mean I keep saying it I say it
all the time and I'll say it again it's
a control trial that compares it to
something meaningful when that trials
going on not only in the United States
but also in other parts of the world you
know right now it's too early to make
any determination but I just want to get
back to what I've said all the time the
definitive way that you get an answer is
by doing a randomized controlled
clinical trial
you're talking about the chloroquine is
that what you're talking about it's
specifically for the last question yes
there are trials going on but they're
also trials going on we're trying them
on people that are now sick that's a
very important that's a very important
whatever happens around the world we're
watching those trends very closely Mitch
McConnell yeah he said that impeachment
diverted the attention of the government
do you think that in any way this was
happening a building at the same time
did it divert your attention or your
team's attention or the vice president's
attention well I don't like to think I
did I think I handle it very well but I
guess it probably did I mean I got
impeached I think you know I certainly
devoted a little time to thinking about
it right so but think of it it was a
hoax it was a total hoax and when you
think that I got impeached only because
they had a majority in the House they
didn't get one then you get one
Republican vote 196 to nothing not one
Republican step I don't think it's ever
happened the Republicans stuck together
and they stuck together in the Senate 52
to a half a half so you know when you
say that yeah I think it took a lot of I
see them going and saying about speed
well they probably illegally impeached
me in the sense that if you look at the
FBI today with what happened the
horrible things nobody cares about that
now because all they're thinking about
is the virus and that's okay with me but
you look at the report that came out
from IG Horowitz it's disgraceful what
went on it's disgraceful
it's a total disgrace they got caught in
the act but but you know what we won't
talk about that now did it divert my
attention I think I'm getting a pluses
for the way I handled myself during a
phony impeachment okay it was a hoax but
certainly I guess I thought of it and I
think I probably acted I don't think I
would have done any better had I not
been impeached
okay and I think that's a great tribute
to something maybe it's a tribute to me
but I don't think I would have acted any
differently or I don't think I would
have acted any faster but the Democrats
the whole the whole life the whole being
their whole existence was to try and get
me out of office any way they can even
if it was a phony deal and it was a
phony deal and it turned out and all you
have to do is look today at the FBI
reports take a look at what the FBI did
take a look at the people take a look at
commis report 78 pages of total kill
take a look at that take a look at the
reporter and McCabe just read it and
you'll see how horrible it was and you
know what I don't think this country is
gonna take it you want to know the truth
how to take us are you offering well
I'll be speaking I'm gonna be a fact he
has a calling to me we'll be speaking to
we'll be speaking to the governor and
we'll be speaking to him soon but
there's a case we have two ships there
are people that are sick in the ship and
we don't want to be like they're gonna
be ghost ships you know people turn
those ships away there was a ship as you
know in a certain part of Asia and from
port to port nobody would take it but in
the meantime you have people that are
dying on the ship or at least very sick
but they're dying on the ship so I'm
gonna out of it you know I'm gonna do
what's right not only for us but for
Humanity I mean these are two big ships
and they have a lot of very sick people
and I'll be speaking to I'll be speaking
to the governor let's do just a couple
of more back here
very much um I was helping you ever run
out of questions but I have nothing else
to do so if you want to I mean if you
want shall we keep it going John I think
Andrew Cuomo today said that the system
that you have where governors are bit
trying to get ventilators it's like
being on eBay with 50 other states
bidding on a family or plus FEMA and
then you just said tonight he was
complaining I say what did he say
exactly what do you think that when you
have States competing for ventilators in
medical care it's like being on eBay
with 50 other states well he shouldn't
be complaining because we gave him a lot
of ventilators and if you take a look at
the chart it's down but I wish he got
going a little bit sooner but we gave
him a lot of ventilators and you know
what he has a lot of ventilators the
problem is with some people no matter
what you give it's never enough it's
never enough like they'll say how scrump
doing and you're a Democrat some of them
said really good
I'll take gavin newsom from california
who's doing a good job by the way and
others said really good but you know
generally your natural reflex House
Trump doing you ask that question to a
Democrat well we don't like it oh really
you don't like it we're getting very
high marks but I'm not doing this for
Marx I'm doing this to save lives when
John acted wait when John saw the
numbers and when Jim saw those numbers
they're shocking numbers you know you're
talking about deaths even at the low end
you were shocked when you see a hundred
and a hundred and twenty thousand and
two hundred thousand people over a
potentially a very short period of time
I want to save lives I'm not doing this
for any other reason I want to save
lives but the governor of New York's
gotten I think maybe you've probably
gotten more than anybody's gotten for
hospitals he's gotten for medical tents
he's gotten a ship the likes of which
nobody's ever seen before
other than Los Angeles which has the
twin I mean we've done a lot but many
ventilators were sent to New York and
mayor de Blasio I'm getting along with
de Blasio great and I think he's very
happy with the job we're doing - we're
sending a lot of actually mayor de
Blasio had an interesting request he
wanted people and we're sending medical
people you know a lot of people a lot of
the states aren't having a problem with
ventilates having a problem getting
medical people and we're sending a lot
of people in military very talented
people and they should call us wait no I
don't want to compress all they're going
to do is drive up the price I don't want
them to compete they should be calling
us and we can work it so they get the
ventilators and they get shipped
directly if they're competing if they're
calling even if there's only two of them
calling they're going to just drive up
the price because as nice as some of the
people that do ventilators they do want
to make money okay now you know you
don't get a chance to buy 16,000
ventilators I guess they didn't take
that option that was in 2016 and that's
a hard option to take because it's a lot
of money and who would ever think you
need 16,000 ventilators who would ever
think it but this is a very unique time
and in life and I think you know I'm
dealing with New York and we're having a
very good relationship and you see what
just happened in Central Park with the
tents I mean we're having a really good
relationship God you get one of those
revenues you mention Devin du cinéma job
yes doing I'm interested in what you
think California has done
suppression of that done a good job
California now let's see what happens
because we could have a spike doctors I
mean you don't know they could have a
spike where all of a sudden spikes
upward we had a couple like Louisiana I
think they're doing a really good job
but they had nothing now they had Mardi
Gras and then all of a sudden after
Mardi Gras which tells you about
distancing I guess I mean it's a it's an
example of what could happen but they
were like flawless I was always
surprised I was looking at Louisiana and
I understand that state I love that
state and I'm saying they're in great
shape then they have Mardi Gras was a
big success tremendous success and then
all of a sudden it went like a rocket
ship so that tells you about distancing
place already concerned there's a
homelessness crisis in California
they're obviously concerned that it
could spread very strongly and I know
that it's it bothers Gavin I don't know
if it bothers Nancy Pelosi but she's got
it in her district at a very high level
they have to be very careful they have a
very big homeless population in an area
which just a few years ago didn't have
anybody in those areas and they're
living in the streets and they're I know
that some people in California are
working on that very hard mr. president
you start several times with Prime
Minister Trudeau a president not crawl
and at the end of last week president
macro talked about an important
initiative that you and him would launch
and he news all that no we're talking
about something that will be very
positive for the world if we do it we'll
see if we do it or not well I don't want
to talk it's it's a private thing but it
will become public if we decide to do it
but positive our relationship with the
president our relationship with France
is you know I think extraordinary very
good probably as good as it's ever been
your comments about what could have
happened the actions that you took
is there any fairness to the criticism
that you may have lulled Americans into
a false sense of security
when you were saying things like it's
going to go away what is and that's
where thing but Jim it's going but when
you were settling to go away hopefully
at the end of the month and if not it
hopefully will be soon after that but
just going on this as you're thinking on
this evolved you're taking it more
seriously I think from the beginning my
attitude was that we have to give this
country I know how bad it was all you
have to do is look at what was going on
in China it was devastation and well
yeah you look at the numbers from China
those initial numbers coming out from
China but you know I read an article
today which was very interesting they
say we wish president Trump would give
more bad news
get bad news I'm not about bad news I
want to get people hope I want to give
people a feeling that we all have a
chance I mean when you suck when you saw
the numbers and when John and all you
saw those numbers and you're saying
120,000 people you mean that's good 100
now dead people within a short period of
time I want to give people a feeling of
hope I could be very negative I could
say wait a minute
those numbers are terrible this is going
to be horrible this is a horrible thing
hey Jim okay let's go to the beach let's
go to the airport let's go down to Mardi
Gras well there were lots people there
were a lot of people that could have
said that we didn't say that
fortunately I didn't say that and that
was an alternative we talked about it
that was always an alternative that's
what I said
let it rip let it ride do nothing and we
could have had two point two million
dead people more than that because I
didn't do that and we did catch it early
and we stopped China really early and we
stopped Europe really early because I
saw what was happening what what
happened is I stopped Italy because
Italy was really heavily infected we
started off with certain parts of Italy
then all of Italy then we saw Spain then
I said stop you're a blood stop Europe
we have to stop them from coming here
Europe I love Europe but they were
having problems I don't think anybody
did a better job than that especially
when you see the 2.2 men
in number and I hope we're gonna be
substantially under the numbers if
you're looking at on the minimum side
then I think we will have hey look it's
still tremendous death I want to be
positive I don't want to be negative I
have to I'm a positive person somebody
said oh I wish you'd be more negative
they literally have that's in one of the
wonderful newspapers today I wish you'd
be more negative well this is really
easy to be negative about but I want to
give people hope too
you know I'm a cheerleader for the
country we're going through the worst
thing that the country's probably ever
seen look we had the civil war we lost
600,000 people right here's the thing
had we not done anything we would have
lost many times that but we did
something so it's gonna be hopefully way
under that but you know we lose more
here potentially than you lose in world
wars as a country so there's nothing
positive there's nothing great about it
but I want to give people in this
country hope I think it's very important
to severe when you were saying this is
all I knew everything I knew it could be
horrible and I knew it could be maybe
good don't forget at that time people
didn't know that much about it even the
experts we were talking about it we
didn't know where it was going
we saw China but that was it maybe it
would have stopped to China we wish we
could have killed it in China but it
didn't happen it started spreading to
Europe it started spreading here it
started spreading all over but and I'm
not blaming anybody I'm just saying that
we have an incredible thing I think the
people are professionals our military
our governor's our politicians I think
they've done an incredible job I mean
with few exceptions I think they've done
an incredible job but I don't want to be
a negative person it'd be so much easier
for me to come up say we have bad news
we're gonna lose 220,000 people and it's
gonna happen over the next few weeks and
with that I did start off by saying
today long before this question I said
this is gonna be a rough two or three
weeks this is going to be one of the
roughest two or three weeks we've ever
had in our country we're gonna lose
thousands of people when I see 28 29
people
from the governor of New Jersey 29
people when you see a hundred and
seventy three people died in New York
yesterday or whatever the number was I
think was more than that when you see
the kind of numbers that we're
witnessing we've never seen numbers like
that so it's easy to be negative and
then everybody could be negative but I'm
a cheerleader for our country and I
wanted to do a great job so the number
can be kept and I've always said it I
want as few a number of people to die as
possible and that's all we're working on
I think it's not meant to be look I know
you well enough so it's not meant to be
a fair question but it is a fair
question I think we've done a fantastic
job okay fine I'll accept your word look
Jim I think we've done a great job we're
going to see how it comes out but when
you look at minimal numbers of 120,000
people when you look at it could have
been 2.2 million people died and more if
we did nothing if we just did nothing
would have gone up and would have come
down as per your statement it would have
been confined it would have been a
similar time maybe even less time it
would have been violence like we've
never seen in this country before we had
great professionals great military
really great governors and politicians I
cannot say enough about what's going on
and as per what you said I think we're
way ahead of schedule in terms of
numbers I think I hope but if we can
keep it under the minimum numbers the
country has there not me the country has
done a great job but I think I've done a
really good job of mobilizing I think
Mike Pence has been fantastic I put him
in charge of the task force we have
wonderful people on the task force Jim
wonderful people that this man was
working literally he had days where he
didn't go to bed he didn't go to sleep
he called he went 24 hours and then
started the next day people don't know
the job he did I didn't even know he was
that good of a manager to be honest with
you Mike okay and you know you never
know that about somebody until they're
tested under fire but he saw it very
early on
so we both did they saw it very early
they knew pretty soon they probably knew
sooner than anybody because that's what
they study that's what they do
must be a depressing business right must
be a little bit depressing but they've
said they've seen it all
go ahead Jim dr. factory question about
a headline that's been running all day I
could get his perspective on it there
was a professor from MIT dr. pouchy who
suggests that coronavirus can be carried
on droplets a distance of 27 feet do you
buy into that and if that might be the
case does that suggest the current
social distancing guidelines may need to
be extended this could really be
terribly misleading John
what it was was looking at the distance
that droplets fly by speaking by
coughing or sneezing so if you go way
back and go on and go like that you
might get 27 feet but so you see
somebody do that get out of the way but
that's not people that is not practical
John I I'm sorry
but I was disturbed by that report Chris
that's misleading that means that all of
a sudden the six foot thing doesn't work
that is a very very robust vigorous
ah-choo sneeze that's what that is and
that's not first you mentioned Franklin
Graham yes suck into him as you know his
father Billy Graham was a trusted
spiritual adviser and friend of many
presidents a lot of your predecessors
and times of national emergency reached
out to pastors and other spiritual
counselors have you done that during
this national abroad I never say that
but frankly Graham is somebody that's
very special I have many very special
people and very many special in the
evangelical evangelical Christian
community you could talk rabbis you can
talk a lot of you know I have tremendous
support from religious leaders and
Franklin Graham I just spoke to him
today for an extended period of time I
told him what a fantastic job you do it
and he does this he loves doing it he
loves helping people and he loves Jesus
that I can tell you he loves Jesus he's
a great gentleman go ahead
sir on the mass maybe for the doctor so
what on the mass is the reason why
there's no CDC recommendation for the
public to wear masks because they're
meant to to save and preserve the masks
for the medical workers or is it because
the virus is not primarily transmitted
through the air there wasn't the CDC
does have recommendations on their
website about mass that came to the
taskforce several weeks ago about if
you're infected wearing a mask to
protect others and if you can't you're
working with someone who's sick and you
have to be that worker in the household
because remember we want people in the
household being taken care of that they
should wear a mask I know your question
is broader than that and it's just being
considered by the task force now about
whether that recommendation that already
exists relevant to wearing masks should
be altered in any way so it's still
under discussion and just about masks
you can get a mask but you can also do I
mean most people have scarfs and scarfs
are very good and they can use a scarf
and where are we talking about a limited
period of time but and it says in the
recommendations you can use you can
substitute a scarf for a mask so if
people feel that and I think you know
some people disagree with the mask for
various reasons and some people don't
but you can wear a scarf you can do the
masks if it makes you feel better we
have no objection to it and some people
recommend it let's go to disturb good
questions actually again I'm looking at
the cases around the world in Latin
America and the Middle East
yes still you don't want to impose it
traveled back for these areas in Brazil
for instance the president also narrow
he keeps on being very active with
groups aren't you afraid that what we're
doing here can be free media people
giving you
not nearby meeting the United States I
mean you're pretty spread out already I
don't have any world but yeah I don't
think what a press conference is anymore
but we're very careful I'm very careful
personally and we are looking at
numerous countries as they get in a
position Brazil as an example you
mentioned the president Brazil had no
problem until just a short time ago and
now they're starting to get inflamed and
yes we are absolutely looking at a ban
there are two other countries you
mentioned Iran already has a ban they
had sort of an automatic ban in addition
to that they have a band so we're
looking at certain countries as they
become I wanted to go to the opening of
the of the hospital in New York and my
people couldn't even believe it that I
said it but I did I wanted to go they
didn't want me to do it the Secret
Service didn't want me to do it for you
know for reasons I want to go to the
boat sailing into New York Harbor but
the governor did a good job of that and
the mayor of New York so you know I'd
love to go out but not be in the White
House and it's sort of like a nerve
center Control Center and I think it's
important you know look you see what
happened with Boris Johnson you see what
happened with others I think it's
important that I remain healthy I really
do so for the most part we're staying
here I've cancelled many different
events and will be staying here for the
most part mr. president Tom Frieden the
former director of the CDC wrote an
article the other day in which he said
what was really needed here and ever
seen
the work that the task force is doing is
an incident commander to really take
command of where everything is going and
how things are being coordinated be
useful in this project for instance we
have his name is Pete Gaynor
he's the administrator of FEMA and when
the President signed the national
emergency declaration he stood up the
National Response Center at FEMA and now
I can tell you that when the White House
coronavirus task force meets I'm at one
end of the table and Pete Gaynor and the
whole FEMA team are by video conference
at the other end of the table and and
that's where whether it be the air
bridge that's literally bringing in
millions of medical supplies from around
the world the thoughtful deployment of
those supplies to hospitals particularly
with regard to ventilators we're working
very closely HHS is fully integrated at
FEMA now but because of the president's
decision to stand up a FEMA in the lead
we have a coronavirus task force at the
White House that's bringing the
president the very best health experts
and recommendations from every agency
but all the implementation as we tell
governor's literally every day is
happening through FEMA it's going down
to the States through FEMA and state
requests are coming up through regional
administrators for FEMA and back to the
White House for the same time we have
4,000 ventilators that are parked in a
warehouse no New Jersey no no no no but
that that was the case we also have we
all we move them that but the question
the question is this happened we also
have people not knowing about the new
Abbot testing facility our testing
system if if there were an incident
command
who was in charge of all of that and
getting the word out with that it was an
invention that we just came up with the
idea a week and a half ago I showed you
yesterday in the box if I may mr.
president I think your points well-taken
the Abbott Laboratories point of contact
test was approved Friday president
announced it in the Rose Garden on
Sunday we're socializing that all across
the country to every governor two
laboratories elsewhere and and I have to
tell you that this team that the
president has assembled the advisors on
the White House coronavirus task force
and then this team at FEMA whether it be
HHS deputy secretary Bob Catholic who's
coordinating all supplies whether it be
Admiral shuwa who is literally working
with every state on a county-by-county
basis to deploy testing is is impressive
and and I think it's given great
encouragement to governor's president I
spoke to governors in all the states and
territories again yesterday because
governors I can tell you from my own
experience as a governor in Indiana we
had tornadoes and flooding governors
know how to deal with FEMA and as soon
as the president stood up FEMA declared
that national emergency what I'll call a
certain amount of muscle memory kicked
in in in states around the country and
we're really seeing a tremendous
efficiency and communication and and
that's how we're gonna go forward again
the president's vision here is FEMA's
vision which is in response to a health
crisis it's locally executed state
managed federally supported and I have
to tell you we're we're seeing that
whole process spinning up every day and
I I hope Americans looking on are
encouraged by that system and I know
they're hearing from governor's around
the country about the flow of resources
and testing and supplies and
we'll continue to keep that would you
call an incident command what what we
call the Federal Emergency Management
Agency working 24/7 in the last less
than a week three governor's call up
that truly have disliked to be over the
years even before I decided to run for
president and they said I have to tell
you you've done a great job you and your
team I've done a great job these are
three governors respected very respected
in two cases and they said like we're
not like you and your team have done an
incredible job but I think they have I
think they've done an incredible job go
ahead please based on whether there
would be a national vodka or some sort
of guidance to every single state that
they needed to so all of the modelers
who presented did I mean I just want to
thank them again because they assembled
from around the globe very quickly about
two or three weeks ago to before we
announce the first 15 days to show all
the implications of closing the schools
having people stay in their homes and
that's how it was modeled stay in your
homes social distancing of six feet so I
know one actually turned it a lockdown
as far as I remember it was more about
staying in your home and I think the
difference was and these weren't in the
models and I think when you talk about
could we have known something different
you know I think all of us I mean I was
overseas when this happened in Africa
and I think when you looked at the China
data originally and you said oh well
there's 80 million people are 20 million
people in Wuhan and 80 million people
and who Bay and they come up with a
number of 50,000 you start thinking of
this more like SARS than you do this
kind of global pandemic I mean I'll just
be frank that's when I
looked at it I was like oh well this is
not you know if as close as those
quarters are you know so I think the
medical community made interpreted the
Chinese data as that this was serious
but smaller than anyone expected because
that I think probably we were missing a
significant amount of the data now that
when we see what happened to Italy and
we hate see what happened to Spain and
so what was modeled is not a lock down
two countries did remove people from
homes that were positive and put them in
separate spaces that also wasn't modeled
but it could be modeled and so we could
go back and ask the modelers about lock
down versus not lock down but what they
modeled was people staying at home with
his best case scenario every state
basically having lockdown behavior not
maybe actual lock downs with basically
everyone's staying in their homes so if
that's anything if that's true
why not tell every state to do that it's
everybody's social distancing by six
feet when they're outside and that is
probably absolutely the key more than
anything else is if you're never more
than if you're never within six feet of
any single individual then you've
controlled the virus there are different
methods to get you to that point and I
think what I've heard from our president
and our vice president is they trust the
American people to understand that they
can be outside take walks be six feet
away from anyone else and be in their
homes and we trust them to do that
without having to lock down I think the
one thing nobody really knew about this
virus was how contagious it was it's so
incredibly contagious and nobody into
that
this is like I don't know that anybody's
ever seen anything like this normally
you'd have to get close and touch this a
lot of things have to happen this is
just like it's it's truly invisible and
so contagious and I don't think any
doctor knew it at the time I don't think
anybody could have known it people have
not seen anything like this the federal
government set the price the federal
government distributes the ventilators
why not have that time system why have
it well essentially we do we've
distributed thousands of ventilators and
we have now thousands of ventilators and
we're buying them at a good price and
we're actually making them by the
thousands we're making them you saw
yesterday where Ford is going to have a
tremendous number they're looking to
make a hundred thousand ventilators Ford
has been great General Electric
Healthcare has been great General Motors
has come a long way I have to be honest
they were working very hard we're making
thousands and thousands of ventilators
you know at the end of this and there
will be don't say I'm optimistic because
I don't want it you know I wouldn't want
to do that but I am optimistic I'm a
very optimistic person let me tell you
we will have thousands of ventilators
and what I want to do is make sure that
we always have plenty for the future but
then we want to help Italy and France
and other countries that you don't even
know about yet with all of the problems
they have because ventilators are very
tough to come by they're very hard to
make very complicated they're very
expensive yeah please you know I can't
take your interpretation of what he said
I don't know what he said I think he's
been reasonably generous considering
there's a Democrat and I think he'd like
to run for president so I think he's
been pretty generous under those
circumstances but he's been very
generous to me look I got him chips I
got him hospitals I got him a lot of
things that he never thought he had paid
hurt okay and I've been very generous on
ventilators if you look they had two
thousand and four thousand they had
thousands of ventilators in his
warehouse in
their warehouse waiting to be picked up
they never picked him up so I'd have to
hear it from him face to face how about
one more and we'll see you tomorrow
is that okay don't say that I cut it
short still say he that's right it could
be almost tomorrow but do not work in
the meantime I'm sure I'm sure people
are enjoying it now it's it's a I will
say this it's an incredibly dark topic
an incredibly horrible topic and it's
incredibly interesting that's why
everybody is it's they're going crazy
they can't get enough of it and they
want to be careful and I guess they're
studying it for themselves just studying
if they get it a lot of people have it a
lot of people are positive and they hope
for the best because when this gets the
wrong person meaning a person that
qualifies generally speaking under the
list it it is ravaging it is horrible go
ahead well how about you is there any
data to suggest that you're gonna see a
second wave at the point at which these
orders well if we do see a second wave
because I've heard dr. fout she answered
this question if we do we're gonna be I
think very well prepared and the second
wave won't be like the first wave and
with that I better let him give you a
little bit more to that answer because I
don't want to have him upset with me and
say I wish you would have answered that
question come on doctor so when you talk
about second wave I think you really
talking about two two different things
that are a little bit different so for
example after the 30 days if we get the
mitigation that we hope will get us to
the suppression that dr. Burks was
talking about there's a danger if we
don't continue to maintain that that
will we have a resurgence right within
the current outbreak that's sort of a
second way but it really is a
exacerbation of the current wave we hope
that doesn't happen and that's why we're
really pushing and why I was so emphatic
about making sure we abide by those
mitigation strategies
the other aspect of a second wave is
something that's just the nature of a
virus that's as the president said
highly transmissible and is going to be
circulating in other parts of the world
as we're going down which I think we
will and I feel certain that we will
then we have to worry about the next
season and as was just mentioned that's
when you use the experience that you
have the interventions that you've
developed and hopefully a vaccine that
you'll be able to deploy as quickly as
you possibly can that's that second wave
that really is more seasonal than an
exacerbation of something that you pull
back on things are happening with the
therapeutics and drugs of different
kinds and the vaccines I think a lot of
very positive things are happening okay
one more please go ahead so under the
worst case scenarios there is a real
scarcity problem if you've given out the
same 7,000 ventilators and we've got ten
thousand around so I'm just curious who
is who signs off on those life-and-death
decisions before GM and Ford Ram is Mike
Pence myself the head of FEMA some of
our generals that are working that are
doing a number you know we have generals
that are working that are unbelievable
talents unbelievable leaders and it'll
go through one of three or four people
if it comes down to that and I hope it
doesn't come down to that because I
think we're very well-equipped and it's
an honor to be here tonight I appreciate
it I appreciate your interest I think
there is a great interest in it and
we'll see you tomorrow